[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys and
welcome back to the leia hile pun show
as always it is powered by icon plus so
some really quick news for you before i
introduce a pretty exciting
guest so um very exciting news from icon
and the popular destination juju island
the early announced blockchain based
covert id contact tracing app that is
using icons did technology
is now fully operational so some news as
always from icon there now
i want to say thank you to my sponsors
block buy i use them to earn up to 8.6
interest on my usdc so that is pretty
insane i'm going to leave a link for you
you can actually get
250 when you sign up so that is some
incredible
passive income for you so i would
definitely recommend that i use that so
they're a really great um
platform for you now before i bring on
my guests just a really quick thank you
to um coinflip so they are doing some
incredible work across the states to
push bitcoin mass adoption
they now actually have 1422 bitcoin atms
which provide access to the everyday
people so
if you're interested in getting some
bitcoin then you can get 10
off all your transactions i'll leave the
discount code for you now
joining me today is a major
international new york times bestselling
author
known for accidental billionaires and
bitcoin billionaires as well as many
other
different stories so it is of course ben
mesmer
ben great to have you how are you doing
thank you i'm doing great thanks for
having me this is this is fun so
awesome yeah i'm really excited to chat
to you
i'm a huge fan of the stories especially
as somebody
um that's a bitcoiner i'm an absolute
fan
so i want to kind of go back a little
bit though because
you're obviously very well known um as a
journalist as a storyteller
um you know from the movie and the
social network and all of this stuff but
can you sort of take talk to us a little
bit about you because
who is ben how did you how did you get
into
um journalism how did you get into
storytelling and also
how would you sort of define yourself
yeah so i've wanted to be a writer since
i was a little kid
i was about 12 when i decided that's all
i wanted to do with my life
i sold my first book right out of
college um
it wasn't an easy process i was rejected
a lot i
i was i had written uh locked myself in
an apartment and wrote uh
nine books the year i graduated from
college which i don't recommend to
anyone
but was rejected by everyone in
publishing i got about 190 rejections
left
um and uh my first book came out nobody
read it and so i used to write
medical thrillers um sci-fi kind of
stuff
until i met the mit blackjack team i
started going to vegas with these guys
i was kind of blown away by it and i
wrote a book called bringing down the
house
which is about these mit kids who took
vegas for millions of dollars
it became the movie 21. and so i became
a journalist by accident i never
intended to be a
fiction writer i wanted to just write
thrillers but that book took off so my
next
you know 15 books or whatever were true
stories
you know i'm always looking for these
revolutionary stories about young people
doing something really cool
um and late one night i got a weird
email
um from a harvard senior who said my
best friend founded facebook
and no one's ever heard of him and it
was eduardo saverin's roommate
eduardo came to me and um and that
began the process of what became the
social network
so that was a really an accident as well
these things have all kind of fallen in
my lap
and uh and so i i describe myself as an
author as a writer it's always ever
wanted to be um but i
i have a deep connection to hollywood so
i usually
write you know i find a story i write a
proposal i sell it as a movie or a
television show
then i write a book and um so i'm known
as a book writer but really i think my
interests are both
you know visual and and in the book form
and
uh and yeah i guess uh you know i'm i'm
an
eccentric reclusive writer but uh but
you know i love that
i fortunately found myself in the center
of
multiple big stories um so um
i always loved michael crichton and i
always my favorite thing about him was
the way he would sort of
write a story and suddenly everyone was
talking about that topic you know
whatever it was and so that's always
what i've tried to do it's it's find
something that's really at the moment
um that it's you know the origin of
something big and cool
um so you know every every book i want
to be about dinosaurs
but you know there's only so many
dinosaurs in the world and so luckily
i've found
you know winklevoss twins that's what's
up yeah
it's been the same kind of thing yeah i
mean i think
okay so firstly i absolutely um
i'm mind blown by the way you can sort
of say you became a journalist by
accident
like that is that is insane you know
like these days you've got to
you've got to get that degree you've got
to go to you know university
wow like you've got to get that there's
a fair number of critics that like the
new york times who think i'm not a
journalist so
let's be fair i did not get the degree i
don't have journalism degree
i i would be a very bad newspaper man um
because
the important thing is the story it's
the thrill fun
it's these heroes and it's not
essentially the little details that one
has to
to pay attention to if one is a a real
journalist so yeah i did fall into true
stories
by accident never i wanted to write
thrillers i wanted to write sci-fi or or
you know da vinci code i wanted to write
the da vinci code and somehow
i found true secret things going on um
you know
bitcoin was one of them but but the
things that i found are something the
whole mainstream
doesn't quite know about yet um that's
always what i'm looking for
yeah and i think um i mean this goes
without saying you absolutely smashed
that
um you know from facebook to bitcoin it
goes without saying but
you've had a pretty interesting week
because you caught the attention of one
of the richest
actually apparently the richest man on
earth elon musk so
you said that you wouldn't turn being um
you went turned down being paid in
bitcoin
again so who did you turn down bitcoin
from i don't know what was it like to
get that attention
but so when i wrote bitcoin billionaires
i had an opportunity to take
the payment for the project in bitcoin
um
you know it's funny as as a as a writer
i'm always the fly on the wall
you know i sit there and i watch and i
listen and i and i tell people stories
and i'm writing about these incredible
revolutions that are going on um but
weirdly i always see myself as not part
of it but someone watching and detailing
the story
not that the objective but real my
reality
is so warped to me it's almost like this
this movie that i'm watching and then
i'm retelling this movie
so of course i should have taken it in
bitcoin i knew
i i you know did you know though did you
know
i've been a believer in bitcoin you know
for a very long time and and the same
way with facebook you know i wrote the
facebook story before
facebook was anything and i had nothing
to be a part of that and
and i've done that in a lot of places
you know i've written books that have
made a lot of other people very wealthy
um but the thing is for me that's not
really my job um
you know i need i need a financial
advisor to read my books and then tell
me what to do
so yes i i i was on to bitcoin very
early
of course there were people who were
onto it way earlier than me um
you know bitcoin billionaires came out
bitcoin was at 3 000 a coin
um so you know of course had i taken
into bitcoin i'd be retired right now
but
but unfortunately you'd still be writing
i i became the objective writer so
it's interesting i'm kind of this like
bitcoin maximalist or whatever you want
to call it
even though i personally have limited
stake in in how bitcoin actually does
other than my belief that you know
the that i i'm supporting people who are
going to do incredibly well with it and
that in turn supports me
um so it's not like i'm disinterested
bitcoin billionaires as a book and as a
movie
rests on bitcoin being bigger and bigger
and bigger but um but i i've been a
believer for a long time i think it
makes sense i think it's smart
i think it's you know it's it's it's a
currency but also a sort of value that
works
in the world we're moving towards um so
i'm happy to see that it is getting
there but um
but yeah i i'm unfortunately i i i
turned down
uh opportunities to be much wealthier
than i am
yeah i think i uh i think we i think
we've all done that we've all sort of
made that mistake at some point but i'm
gonna get to sort of your opinions on
bitcoin
and where you see it in a bit but i want
to talk about
um the social network and the accidental
billionaires um
because like you said you received that
really
weird sort of encrypted message from
eduardo um
out of absolutely nowhere so just tell
us what on earth were you thinking
um yeah go for it email there's this guy
named will mcmullen who was one of
eduardo's roommates at harvard this was
2009 i would guess it was it was a while
for those who don't know who eduardo is
just so if you bought
little network eduardo saverin is the is
the one who co-founded facebook
and then mark kicked him out of the
company um eduardo ended up
suing for billions and billions of
dollars
and called me so i didn't know this at
the time
but eduardo had reached out to me in
this sort of machiavellian idea that
he was in the midst of suing zuckerberg
who had cut him out entirely
um diluted into zero he wasn't even on
the masthead of facebook anymore
um and he thought if i could if he could
talk to a writer
it would scare zuckerberg enough that
zuckerberg would pay him off
and that's exactly what happened you
know he basically came to me
and we spent you know some months
talking about it and i wrote a book
proposal
so i wrote a 14-page book proposal which
i think i called
face off i believe okay a movie called
face off anyways it was called face off
and my book proposal leaked onto the
internet onto a website called
gawker.com if you remember gawker
and that day facebook settled with
eduardo for what became five
billion dollars and on the top of the
settlement agreement it says you may
never speak to ben mesrick again
because they were hoping to just cut him
off and cut me off and make it not
happen
so he was five billion dollars and
disappeared to singapore
never to be heard from again and he cut
off all contact with me
he should send me a gift basket i mean i
got only million dollars
one billion yes you know
10 million in eduardo where are you
eduardo one million
yeah but but in any event he got very
rich and he disappeared but i already
had enough to write the book and then i
met the
lost twins so i reached out to them on
facebook of all places
i you know knew they were part of the
story um and they were very generous
with their time and proceeded to sort of
be
sources for what became the social
network now at the time they were the
bad guys in the story
i saw them as kind of the bad guys they
were the big giant
blonde guys who were chasing the karate
kid around the gym just the skeletons
right
i mean that that's how i because i grew
up the 80s were a big part of my life
and
and to me those are the 80s bad guys
those are the guys in
every 80s movie who beat up the good guy
so
that's how i saw them i didn't think
much beyond that i knew they were
incredible athletes i knew they had this
incredible
uh you know deep like american belief in
entrepreneurialism and getting back up
if you're down they don't lie
these are very honest guys which i think
was very intriguing
in the whole social network they're the
only two people who don't ever lie
um everyone else is kind of duplicitous
and you know there's sean parker there's
zuckerberg
there's eduardo but the the the winning
austrians are straight you know
they they end up being the bad guys
because because they're so straight in a
way
so yeah so i never thought i'd write
about that again i thought that was the
end of that story
um until years later um so yeah i don't
know if you want me to go into the
bitcoin store
i'll ask you no we'll get there but um
just at that moment though
um did you realize what facebook was
right like
like you said you sort of stumbled onto
two revolutions
facebook and bitcoin so you stumbled
onto facebook
did you have any idea that it was going
to be facebook and also just
not just facebook but just like the
beginning of something
so before watching me yeah my wife was
on facebook and that was about all i
knew about it you know
pictures that i didn't know what was
going on and i was like what is this
thing that everyone's on i knew about it
you know
i had gone to harvard so we'd hear you
know everyone kind of
and stuff like that um but in the
process of talking to eduardo and then
sean parker spent a lot of time with
shawn
um with all these other kind of insiders
i i really started to believe this was
life-changing it wasn't just my speech
you know we're friends there
or one of these other things would come
before facebook was going to change the
fabric of all of our lives
now i also believe that zuckerberg um
was madeline michael he was one of these
people who would believe that we should
all be on facebook he didn't believe in
privacy
he didn't believe that you should hide
things from other people because the
world becomes a better place
if we share everything so he wanted to
turn the world into this facebook
village
and there are dangers to that which we
are now seeing um but i really thought
you know this is a revolution this is
life-changing this is
a world built you know for people who
who don't want to interact in person but
want to interact online and that's what
we were moving towards
so i did see it as a revolution and
that's why i wrote the book
it wasn't just a book about another
company i never saw it as that
and i'll tell you what aaron when aaron
sorkin and fincher got involved
i remember when aaron sorkin told me the
title is going to be the social network
and i thought that's a horrible title i
didn't think much of it
um right you know when you think about
it it actually is a really good title
because the point is is that
this could be anything it didn't have to
be a specific company
it didn't have to be you know about a
guy who makes a billion dollars the
point was
this is the network that we now all live
on
and that's kind of why that title works
so well so so yeah i did see it as a
revolution at the time
but did you i mean you don't have to go
into too much detail on this but
given what we've seen with donald trump
you know his sort of social media band
this week did you think
ever that you that we would get to that
you'd be working on a platform which or
covering a platform
which actually bans the sitting
president of the united states
it's been a wild run i will say i think
with the social network we got mark
zuckerberg exactly right
and we got what facebook was going to
become exactly right
um if anything you know i predicted that
we would all spend most of our days on
facebook at this point
i really thought facebook i didn't see
twitter coming you know
i uh facebook would be the thing that
where we
where i thought it would encompass all
of that because i really felt like he
was creating a platform
where you didn't need to do anything
else you didn't need to have enough
internet
it was a whole silo that we would all
live
inside of um interestingly enough there
are five of them or whatever
um facebook didn't swallow them all it
tried
and it swallowed yeah that didn't
swallow all of them but yeah you know we
are in a crazy moment where
these things are dangerous listen we you
and i you as well
we live on twitter we live on facebook
we use these things because they're
such a big part of how we reach people
and how we speak to people and how i get
my stories people pitch me things on
twitter
all the time and it works for me but
they're also dangerous
because they also bring out this sort of
dark underside
of the world um where you know
people aren't responsible necessarily
for what they say or they do
and that's dangerous um so there needs
to be a way to make people responsible
for what they
say and do i love twitter but the thing
i hate about twitter
is that nobody's responsible for
anything they say and that's not a
good thing um you know you should be
able to say what you want on twitter
but there will be ramifications to it
and and that's that's
not a bad thing um so you know it's it's
an interesting
it's an interesting world yeah i think
it's interesting what you say about
facebook when you say sort of wanted to
be
everything just because in my opinion i
actually think that's its downfall
um i think what twitter does really well
is that it just stays to one thing and i
hate the fleets
um i think no it just needs to stay to
one thing just conversation in a niche
market and i think that's what it does
well yeah absolutely you know the
simpler the better
for me that's how i use twitter i mean i
never really got into all the other
magical things that you can do with it
but listen twitter is world changing
it's brilliant and
and i think it can be this incredible
tool um we've seen it used incredibly
well
so many ways but at the same time there
are dangers to it and i think that you
know we see that happen all the time as
well
so what were your initial thoughts about
mark zuckerberg um he's sort of this
controversial character
right well he doesn't like me very much
let's put it that way i i really wanted
to interview him i wanted to sit down
with him and get rid directly from him
and he just refused i spent a year
um you know i got to sean parker who was
a very big source the winklevoss twins
you know eduardo
all of these people around him but mark
just wouldn't talk to me he couldn't
control what was gonna write
he was afraid because i was talking to
the winklevi that that you know i was
biased against him whatever um but i i
think he's an absolute genius i think he
really
the power behind what facebook is and
became i don't think he sees the world
the rest the way the rest of us does i
think he's very socially awkward and
strange
i think he he's one of these people who
is happiest and most comfortable in
front of a computer screen
and everything else you know is is a
delusion to him i think he's very
much um this regimented automaton
i think he's a he's somewhat a robot and
i think to him
friendships don't mean the same thing
they mean to everyone else at least from
eduardo's perspective eduardo thought
mark was his best friend
i don't think mark ever thought that
about eduardo and so i think that
there's
this disconnect between him and people
um which is a little scary when you
think about it
but i also am amazed and and intrigued
by him i think he's incredible
i'd happily write a mark zuckerberg book
if you want to come tell me his story
um the social network is is from the
point of view of eduardo i think i think
more than it is
it's from the point of view of the
people around him and i think you can
tell a very good true story
from the point of view of the people who
surround the story um
not necessarily meeting the man in the
center um but it would be a very
different story told from mark's point
of view
yeah i think that's really interesting i
didn't that didn't really occur to me um
when i sort of followed the story
um that it was from eduardo's
perspective that's pretty interesting if
you read extra billionaires it's
definitely more
more from eduardo's point of view yes
it's a network i think aaron sorkin
worked very hard
to tell it from mark's point of view um
so there that is a very different
perspective i think
um but um listen it's a great movie i i
think it's it is
one of the best movies of the last 10
years and i think uh it will remain that
way
um you know for a while yeah so
so bitcoin billionaire sort of begins
where
this one finishes so can you tell us
where you first
heard about what was going on right like
you have
the winklevi which i still find so funny
that people call the wink of eye
um you have them sort of coming into all
this money going to silicon valley
nobody wants to work but then they go to
ibiza like
how did you even hear about this story
yeah so i i you know i was done i didn't
think i was going to write about the
winklevoss twins again they were
perfectly nice we got along great
um they even came to the movie premiere
they were cool
but um but i thought their story was
over bitcoin was something that people
had been pitching me
blockchain and bitcoin you know because
i'm a writer in that world but i was not
interested yeah
math and it was the word blockchain i
hate that word
it's a terrible word i don't write about
bitcoin um and then i
my wife was reading the new york times
and there was an article and it that's
the title the article was
bitcoin the the winklevoss twins are the
first bitcoin billionaires
and i was like is this possible how do
these guys do this and so i called
and i went out to new york and i sat
down with the twins and i was like tell
me what's going on here
and i was blown away by the idea that
these guys were at the forefront of two
revolutions
you don't usually see that their story
should have been over um they got a
payday
out of facebook that you know ended up
being a lot of money
um it was originally 67 million but they
took it in stock and
yes a billion dollars and they smartly
um you know uh uh ended up in something
else and
and so as they proceeded to tell me all
about bitcoin and sort of
how they found it and why it was a
revolution
i i began to see more and more that this
was something really important and
significant
and the fact that they had bought so
heavily you know as many as 200 000
coins
seven dollars a coin um uh that it was
going to be life-changing not just for
them but that they became part of the
story in such a very big way
um and and and so i dove in and uh over
the course of a year
with them and following all the
different you know charlie shrim and all
the different
og's in the bitcoin world that i could
speak to um
eric voorhees and roger roger there and
all these different people
uh i learned a lot and i i sort of you
know i'm not an expert
in in any way like someone who could
actually do computer stuff but i think
i've become an expert in terms of what
bitcoin is and what it means and
why it's important and why it's
significant and then that process
um yeah i became a believer um but as a
writer for me the important thing is
this thriller this story
i would not have ever written about
bitcoin if it were not the winklevoss
twins
um because that's to me what sells this
story you know it's not europe that
there's a bunch of people who figured
out a way to make money better
uh the story is these guys who were the
bad guys in the social network
fell into a whole other revolution and
rode a whole nother crazy drama
to great success um and that's fun and
so that's that's why i wrote it yeah
so do you think it's a coincidence then
that you have these guys
who you know are they they come from a
wealthy background
you know they're at harvard um but
actually they're at the forefront
of two huge revolutions and i think
actually
like i'm gonna predict this i'm gonna
say that facebook and bitcoin will be
the two
biggest revolutions of the next decades
to come
um just just because i think they set
the foundation right like something else
bigger could come along but like
i think that will be a sort of product
of these two things so
yeah i mean i think you're probably
right but i think you know i don't think
it's an accident or a coincidence that
they haven't
been there twice i think it goes back to
who they are and you get that out
but these are guys who yes they do come
from great wealth so you could see them
just
riding off into the sunset after
facebook but these are guys who really
feel
that they want to build something that
they have to prove something that they
have to do something
great and that comes from their father
and from their background these are not
guys who would ever just sit around on a
beach for a year
these are very intense people and that's
kind of how they come out as the bad
guys in the social network
yeah it's real if you spend time with
them they're very intense
and there's two of them so it's not like
you know you feel like they can do
anything
and i think that they they set out to
find a revolution
um they wanted to create something great
they felt like it was robbed
they were stolen um they believed that
they were the reason that facebook
succeeded that they were the people
behind
some of the smart things that made
facebook work and that
mark stole it from them that he cheated
them that he lied and they weren't going
to
sit down and let that happen they were
going to find another way to build
something great
and so when they stumbled into bitcoin
that's what drove them to
to be so crazy to take a risk and to
dive in headlong
um so i don't think it's a coincidence
but you know
they they managed to you know find
something great twice
um and and that's that's doesn't happen
often so yeah
yeah yeah it's pretty it's pretty insane
i think it's kind of one of those things
where it's kind of like i think
luck is just a manifestation of being
incredibly prepared
you know of preparation so if you look
at it this way they were lucky to
stumble into bitcoin when it was seven
dollars a coin
and you could say they were lucky to
have the money to buy
that many coins but most people would
buy it seven dollars
and sell at fourteen dollars or exactly
two dollars or a hundred dollars or a
thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars
forty the facebook shares you know so
how do you hold it
all the way to here that's not luck
anymore um that's a belief in something
that's doing your research and deciding
if this is the next big thing
um so a lot of us could have gotten
lucky and bought bitcoin
and this is how i you know feel better
about myself i could have taken bitcoin
at 3
000 and i would have sold it at 6 000.
it's very unlikely
i would have had the guts to hold it all
the way to here um
and most people didn't um so you know
it's it's uh
you have to give it to them they
definitely believed a hundred percent
what they were doing
so in the first one like we said they
were sort of the jocks they sort of came
across quite evil in the second you know
we sort of learn a bit more about them
and we
we like them a bit more so how did they
sort of take to that portrayal of them
in the first one and actually
you know they were i guess okay with it
because they were happy to go on and do
the second i mean listen they don't
agree with all of that portrayal
fantastic army was emerging in it um and
and they
i think they really you know they saw
aspects of themselves that definitely
came out and to be fair unless no one
else was telling their story
um this was their story being told in a
very big way
um and they had essentially been cut out
of history you know facebook was this
huge thing
and they were being left behind um and
both them and eduardo
saw this as their reckoning you know
that here we are
but the winklevoss queens definitely
believed they were more than you know
these guys
who were just rowing and eating in the
dining hall they felt like
more guys who were doing something great
and mark sort of snuck in and stole it
but i think overall they love the social
network
they believe that it was a true telling
of the story
um you know i've seen them interviewed
about it and they they said it was a
good
good telling of what happened that year
um but
they are much more than that and i think
that comes out later yeah
so if you sort of have to look back and
and
sort of think you know all of all of
this has happened what are your thoughts
then
just on i guess on all of it now because
we we've seen
you know they've so i'm looking at i'm
looking at mark zuckerberg and i'm
looking at the wink winklevoss twins and
sort of what they've done
and we've got the winklevoss twins with
gemini
and then we've got um mark zuckerberg
who's just started well not just started
but they're sort of pushing with with
libra
yeah quite interesting so it's really
funny i believe
that i've always said this but i think
zuckerberg wakes up every morning
thinking of the wink of lost twins
and i think that we can wake up every
morning thinking about zuckerberg they
deny that they say that's not true
but i feel like that there's this
shakespearean drama between these people
that they're locked into this massive
battle that goes on for decades
there's no way in my mind that
zuckerberg does not know about
gemini and the wink of austrians in
bitcoin i mean come on
and then he launches his own coin called
libra
there's no way that's a coincidence okay
it's just a it's a weird
thing going on i think that zuckerberg
is looking at
crypto he has to be i mean everybody in
the industry is looking at crypto
and he wants part of it he knows it's
something that they missed
most of silicon valley missed it they
just didn't see this happening
and the lost twins did and so in a lot
of ways what's really cool about the
story
is it's flipped on its head you know
facebook was the revolution and the wink
of oz twins were the establishment
and now league of lost twins are the
revolution and facebook is the
establishment
i mean you can't ask for more
storytelling than that
um perfect kind of situation but yeah i
don't think zuckerberg's going to leave
it alone and i think we're going to see
them move into
crypto in a big way yeah it it it's
pretty insane um
because i think you're absolutely right
in terms of like that flip um
flip on its head that that flip on it on
the establishment but then
what are your thoughts on sort of just
facebook right now i guess because a lot
of people and in my opinion i sort of
feel like it's declining like i don't
use facebook i'm actually going to
delete it
um i just i actually don't know how to
delete it that's the only reason why
but we haven't moved on and we're all on
instagram though so it's like you know
yeah yeah i mean what's the difference
instagram is essentially
overtaking i think facebook at least in
a generation that's going on now
in in terms of the importance to their
life but it's still facebook i don't
i don't see a distinction between
facebook and instagram so if you're
gonna include instagram in that no i
don't think it's losing any power over
the over the younger people
i think facebook as itself feels clunky
now it feels too slow it feels
you know dirty there's all these crazy
you know
political stuff going on there's fake
stuff going on but i still use it in
terms of looking at memories and
pictures i think that's the fun part
about facebook right now
but i don't really use it to communicate
so much um i don't use it as i did
maybe seven years ago right but i use
instagram way more than i would have
thought a year ago
because it's a fun quick it's more
streamlined it seems more
what facebook was um but yeah in terms
of
facebook itself i could foresee it
becoming less
and less the important part of the giant
you know
thing that's nominating our lives but it
doesn't really matter to me what format
is it's all the same
it's the social network it's the idea
that we're on this
internet based society now um
um so there will be better and better
forms of it um but i think we're all
still part of it i don't think you're
gonna get away from it by deleting
facebook
i was watching um i was watching a
netflix documentary about
social networking and all this stuff and
they have um
they have actual ethical positions right
like so you know how you have like um
like an officer for like diversity and
gender and all this stuff like they now
have like
the ethics right social media so you've
got to give me your
take what do you think is going on
because you know it's it's addictive
um that you know it's the the privacy
and the data issues
um there are a lot of ethical issues so
what's your take
yeah i mean i think that facebook really
uh
it became dangerous simply because they
worked very hard to make sure it's a
part of all our lives and important
to do that they had to find tricky ways
to get us all addicted to it
and they had to study ways of getting us
more and more addicted to it and then
the fact that they make money off of our
data
and it really leads to these enormous
ethical issues about privacy and things
like that
and as generations come up they care
less and less about privacy because of
it
i think young people don't care about
privacy so much they want to put things
on instagram and facebook
you know they put themselves in front of
their house on facebook on instagram all
the time
not thinking about what information that
gives away because and i do too
listen because we want to share we want
we all want to be
you know in front of everyone we know
it's just we're social animals and then
in the covid situation we see it more
and more people
want connection so badly that they're
willing to put all their data up
and then places like facebook monetize
it which is the scary part
um so there are huge ethical questions
and issues that come to something like
this
um but putting that aside i don't think
this is a bad thing
i think the idea that facebook started
with and then mark started with was not
bad i don't think he would rule the
world as an evil emperor
i think you really believe the world is
a better place if we're one big village
if we all you know if you know the
person who lives in another country
personally on facebook that makes you
closer to them
and less likely to fight with them right
in a way it does work you do
have a happier world that we can all
connect i think that's all true
so the question is how do we have a
happier world that we all connect in
knowing that there's all these bad
people in it knowing that there's all
these people who have
nefarious reasons to want to connect or
people who want to make money off of
connecting or all these different things
how do you work with that and so these
are big difficult ethical questions
that have to be answered and i think as
facebook grew that wasn't their goal
answering these ethical questions the
only goal was grow
how do we grow and grow and grow now
they're going to have to look back and
say okay
you can't do this we shouldn't do this
you know and so i think it's okay that
they're hiring people to sort of look
into this
i think it's possible regulation
self-regulation is is better than
outside regulation but self-regulation
is being proven not to work
so you really need to find ways that to
regulate this stuff
in a way to make it healthy um and to
make it happy but
i don't have the answers look if you
look at what's going on with politics
and parlor and twitter
and there's no good answer to all this
sort of thing there are answers and some
people are going to hate those answers
and some people aren't i mean you
shouldn't use twitter to foment
you know negative things violence and
revolution and all that kind of stuff
but on the other hand you should be able
to use twitter to state your opinions
so how do you how do you how do you
police that and that's not an easy thing
i don't think there's an
easy way to look at it yeah i think it's
a topic that you can just speak about
for ages um
you know especially given everything
that's going on right now but i think
the biggest thing which
not forget like the d platforming of the
bloody you know
president of the united states the
sitting president forget that um
despite the tweet that he was uh the
platform for not actually being
something which incited violence at all
um facts um i think what kind of
got me though was the um
the kind the the destruction of parlor
like that got me because it's an
interesting thing but here's the thing
and i i have mixed feelings about all
this i'm not going to be on one side or
the other and i know there's going to be
people who are
angry on both sides if i say something
in the middle but you know
listen i think we need to live in a
better world
we should be kind and great
to each other and nice to each other all
the time and all that this device that
needs to go away so how do we get there
the end goal okay
the end goal shouldn't be a party or
politics or a point of view the end goal
should be everyone's happy and no one
hurts anybody
that's the only goal we should be
working towards so the question is how
do you get to that goal
and if you think your way of getting to
that goal is the right way then you
should put that forward
but if you think your goal your way of
getting that goal that goal isn't
important
then i don't know how we have a
conversation the goal is only a better
happier safer world
and so for me you know i look at the
parlor situation and yeah
i mean there's monopolistic things going
on and they're trashing stuff like this
to try and
but what's the goal you know and that's
what you have to keep in mind i'm not
saying it's right
but i'm just saying we have to keep one
goal in mind and so i don't know enough
about parlor to make a decision about
what was going on on there
i i haven't been on them um so you know
listen people should be able to put
their points of views up
um but there needs to be policing a
point of view i really don't believe
that free speech reaches the point where
you can say i want to kill somebody
it just doesn't you know why if people
can say things like that
then the world is worse uh so okay
let's make the world better you
shouldn't be able to say anything you
want i really don't think that's what
free speech
is all about you really shouldn't you
can't say hateful things and if you're
willing to say hateful things
people should be allowed to not listen
to you and if there's a
way of doing that um we should do it so
i'm not a fan of
of violent hate speech i don't think i
ever will be and i don't think someone
can convince me
that we should be a fan of violent hate
speech i'm not saying parlor is that i
don't know enough about parlor
but i can be a reason why we don't want
to foment
violent hate space i mean i think that's
something we should
endeavor self-endeavor i think
self-regulation is the way to do it 100
i think people should look at themselves
and say okay this is a hateful violent
thing to say
so i'm not going to say it but there are
always going to be people who are always
going to say
hateful violent things right so what do
we do about that do we just let them say
hateful violent things
i mean i think you're a true libertarian
and you don't care what the world looks
like you say everyone say anything you
want
but i don't want that world i i don't
want my kids to grow up in a world
where people around them are just saying
hateful violent things
because they have free speech do you
when you're kids at school
do you want the person next to them to
be saying hateful violent things because
they have the freedom
to i mean you don't you don't want your
kids sitting next to someone saying that
right
so why are you okay with it on the
internet so i okay so i think school is
a little different
but i think i think the problem the
problem with with sort of policing
speech
and i'm a huge fan of jordan peterson
jordan peterson to me is just like an
idol like i'm
in awe of everything he has to say i
can't fault him in the slightest but
he talks a lot about sort of looking at
speech and sort of understanding um
you there's hate and there's violence
right so that they're two different
things
and i think how how you know what might
be hateful to you
may not be hateful to somebody else what
might be offensive to you may not be
defensive you're absolutely right but in
reality no
i think in reality we kind of know what
hates it it's like pornography you know
what it is when you see it
you know yeah you see it and we can play
the the literal you know the linguistic
game all the time and say
well to someone who you know lives there
that's not so hateful
but the reality is you know it when you
see it and and well i think it's i think
it's objective when you're committing a
crime you know when you're committing a
crime
and i believe deep down that the people
saying hateful things
no they're saying hateful things they
know it
but they say it because they want to i
think
there's a percentage of people that are
just bad let's be honest
and the problem with the libertarian
point of view and i i am a libertarian
but the problem with the libertarian
point of view is that there are very
bad people out there so you can't just
they're bad on the other side as well
like
i think there are bad people on both
sides so yes it has to be equitable
100 i think there's plenty of things
that both sides i'm not
liberal and i'm not on the left i think
there are plenty of things on both sides
that are hateful horrible things
and should be pleased i just don't
believe in the free-for-all
i really don't and and i believe in
freedom
you know to an extent but but violence
and hate
are just not good things and there
should be a way to stop them but i agree
i'm not the person who could make that
decision
and that's where we get into problems
who makes that decision how do you make
that decision
and we aren't at a point where we have
an objective way of doing that
so i'm i agree with you 100 that
de-platforming people left and right
is a very dangerous thing because god
only knows who's who's making the
decision how they're making those
decisions
but i do agree that there are people who
should be de-platformed
so that's where we differ i think that
de-platforming the way it's done
is is not inequitable and it can be very
dangerous but i do believe there are
people who should not
be speaking and that's that's that's the
way i look at the world
a small percentage of people should not
have freedom of speech
because they're bad people and how do
you pick those bad people
out i'm not saying they're on withside
or on that side but we all know that
they exist
right yeah i i think often like that
line gets blurred and i'm very much of
the opinion sort of when you
give an inch they take a mile and that's
exactly what we see on twitter because
um
i've seen a lot of people being sort of
banned for misgendering somebody by
accident
right now and i agree with you 100
stupid and you know what
listen i i'm not a fan of this this like
canceling people for statement
theology i mean come on i'm a writer i'm
a journalist i think people should put
their ideas out there
tell stories i think it's disgusting
when a professor writes an article and
everyone disagrees with the article and
they want to ruin his career
that's absurd right but i also think
that there are people who say something
hateful and violent
and they should they shouldn't they
shouldn't say it and they should be
stopped from saying it
um it shouldn't be propagated you know
if something is is truly violent and
hateful
it doesn't need to be amplified i have a
question i have a question then just on
that point then um
so my mentality is and my question to
you is
often i quite enjoy hearing these things
because
it tells me who this person really is
like i
it really shows me the truth and can i i
really want to just take i always
here's a really extreme example right so
i want to take hitler as an example
so i'm pleased that
we are able to know what he said and
what he did and we can hear his true
opinions i just think it's so
important to hear this um because
otherwise we don't know how long that
war could have gone on for
you know if things were if things you
know if we didn't hear if the opposing
side didn't come in
you know if everything was done very
quiet and and
you know i mean i know that was their
goal anyway in nazis
to be done quite quietly um but
in those kind of cases i like i i'm glad
that i know where he stands i'm
you know there are plenty of um the the
iranian
um the iranian leader was his
exactly he's on twitter but i know where
he stands and i'm glad that i do
um and now you're right you're
underground i'm glad that i know and
that
jack hasn't de-platformed him yes taking
thinking he's de-platformed
trump i know the truth i really value
that i agree and there's that's the hard
part is where you draw this line because
you want to hear these people's points
of view because you want to know where
they stand and what they believe and i
think it's important to know that
but do you want it to then become a call
to action did you want him
no i'm not call to actions no hitler
went on twitter
and was trying to rally people to do
something awful you'd be against it and
you'd say cut this
twitter i'm not saying anybody is hitler
but i'm saying there has to be a line so
someone has to draw the line so you
you do agree with me that there has to
be policing so that's the problem with
the libertarians this is hard
it's hard you just disagree with where
they're policing it
but not that they're policing it i think
i think i think i think it's just so
hard to draw that line and i'm very
i'm very um conscious of giving an inch
and then taking a mile i mean honestly
if it was nowadays
we disagree i just think that i i'm i'm
more jaded than you are and i believe
that
there's just some bad bad actors out
there
and you know what if if less people
spoke we'd be better off
that's that's that's my chicken i get
that though
let's everyone just be quiet unless you
have something really good to say
because you know don't say something
unless it's not what does it do
if it's not nice don't say it or
whatever it wasn't
like i just wish the world were like
that and i get that it's not
but i live in a delusional world i live
in a delusional you know fairyland with
unicorns and
and and i want to live in a world with
unicorns and winklevi and why can't i
just live with that world
so i think you know i think my brothers
have always described me as like a
muppet
so when people ask me where politically
you are i'm like i don't think muppets
have politics
i think other than that eagle on the
muppets all of the muppets kind of
believe that the world just get along
and go along so i
i'm not i don't really have a political
point of view or a political horse in
all of this
but i i do understand that listen
de-platforming people is dangerous and
scary
but there are also people who should be
d platforms i think i can hold both
those thoughts and listen these are
nuanced things
you can't just say it on the internet
that's the other problem with the
internet i don't make any political
statements on twitter or anything like
that because there's no nuance on
twitter
anything you say is one second and then
flips it will piss off a lot of people
i think in a conversation it's great to
have these conversations and it's
important
um but there's no nuance on the internet
right so
that that may be tricky to ever say
anything
and the limited characters are exactly
part of their um
part of their sort of gameplay um so you
are so you've been at the party you've
been at the center of two of the biggest
revolutions of the decade not just the
winkle vibe but you as well of course
we've been at the center
and documenting it so what can we expect
um any more interesting things coming up
i mean i know you want to write
i've been chasing elon musk i've had my
midnight conversations i really would
love to do
and i know there's been an elon musk
biography which is great and all that
kind of stuff what i want to tell
if i could is really a thriller about
the specific things this battle he's
fighting against ai and to expand our
consciousness and to reach mars i think
there's a great thriller
and movie to be told about this guy
doing this crazy thing
and and succeeding so the way i would
approach the story would be
specific like that i lo i would love to
write an elon musk book
um but i don't have landed you know for
me i need access to the main character
or characters around him
enough to tell me the story i don't want
to just write another story
around elon i would love for him to just
talk to me and i think i could get there
but that's that's what
i'm working on personally i have a big
book coming out i wrote a uh
a serialized novella for the boston
globe over the summer which ran
it was called the mechanic and it was a
da vinci code style thriller
going back to the american revolution
that was really fun and cool
i wrote it chapter would go up one night
and i'd literally write a chapter a day
and it ran weeks and it was very
successful we had a huge readership
so i sold the movie to steven spielberg
and amblin and i'm writing the
screenplay
and then i'm working on the book will be
out next winter
and then a sequel the following year so
that's i don't have a big non-fiction
book yet
so i'm looking for stories so people
want to tweet to me
send me a story i'm always searching for
a big enough story
to tell elon of course would be a great
one but whatever i
i can find in that world but i i you
know tell you what's next or what you
should invest in next
um i don't know great question uh i
think what's going on in biology is
awesome i wrote a book called woolly
um which was all about crispr technology
and and uh but that's very hard
you know it's not it's not as easy to
sell a book
as anything else so you know i think
what's going on with vaccines and covid
is a is another sea change in revolution
i think these new vaccines have come out
are going to change the world because
you're going to have vaccines for cancer
you're going to have vaccines for
alzheimer's you're going to have
vaccines for everything
and you know there's going to be people
on both sides of that too but um but
this mrna
technology is really world-changing um
but
i don't know what's next i'm always
looking for the next big thing
i thought it was absolutely hilarious um
when elon musk replied to you just sort
of saying i don't have the time
right i need to i'm trying to save
listen i don't want him to sit there and
write books i want him to change the
world for the better he's one of them
you can just follow him with your
notepad and be like
i i think the winklevoss twins can tell
elon that i don't bother you too much
you won't even know i'm there i'm just
like a fan i'm like a fanboy
i i have been criticized by a lot of
journalists that i fall in love with my
main characters
and it's really true i write about
someone to me they're always larger than
life even when they're bad guys
um like russian oligarchs or whatever
else i've written about i always kind of
want to tell their story in the best way
possible so i would say to elon musk i
want to tell the story that you want to
tell
i want to tell the way you want to tell
it um which is very different than like
a biography or something like that so
we'll see if i get to him um but uh you
know there's a lot of white whales out
there so
i'll keep searching with my harpoon just
last question for you then um
because you said you know you're sort of
living in this um
this fantasy world with your unicorns
and the wink of eye and all this stuff
so elon musk has some pretty wild
um um opinions and one of them which i
would love one day to interview him
about and just
really just like um just really want to
scrutinize this idea of his is that
we're living in a simulation
yeah um so i i'm just so bothered by
that um and i really
i i like i don't i have some that i have
some um
like uh like what is it how do i put
this
i have some ways i want to critique it
basically but what do you think do you
think we're living in a simulation
i'm a big believer in the simulation
theory i have to say i'm not 100
convinced nine percent convinced that
word
not that it matters because i don't
affect the stimulation i don't think you
can discover it and then not be
in it anymore but i do feel that
looking at the math of it that it seems
very
interesting to me i mean if you look at
the development of ai
and you look at the development of sort
of how computer games work and you look
at you know
they're getting better and better and
very i just look at the video games that
i play today versus the video games i
played
when i was in college you know that a
hundred years from now these video games
are going to be indistinguishable from
reality
and then the idea that that these
non-human players the computer players
are going to have their own
intelligence at some point it seems
likely
to me anyways i know there are problems
with that to me
so the idea that we're all in a
simulation just
it kind of makes sense right i'm not
saying you can actually see it or notice
it
yeah you know it's really interesting
i was blown away by simulation theory
when i first fell into it years ago
and uh have done a lot of reading into
it um
it doesn't change anything that's the
weird thing but i i do think that
yes that's what's going on what do you
you don't think so or you don't want oh
no
no no i'm cool with it like i'm i'm i'm
an absolute i'm i'm an absolute sci-fi
freak i love all that stuff i'm i'm down
with that
sure absolutely that's mine my issue is
but who says that we are the first to
get there that's what i'm saying like i
agree
you know we were doing um it was it was
just um
like the pongs and the ball and you know
what i mean
yeah and then that now is about now we
can't really tell the difference so i
get that we're gonna get that and i also
think that like
humanity this is probably you won't like
this opinion but humanity is just so
inherently flawed that i don't think
we'll ever get to a point whereby we say
that's immoral so we shouldn't control
them definitely don't think that will
happen
definitely think we'll get there but who
says that they're there before us
why are we not the first ones i mean we
you know
you could right but if time is nearly
infinite
then we couldn't be the first ones right
because over a
vast amount of time the likelihood that
this moment in time is the first time
that happened
gets smaller and smaller and smaller i
don't get that
that's the better i get there's an
infinite point there's infinite
points along the timeline um so it goes
on and on and on and on and on and there
are
essentially potentially
infinite places this could be happening
um
so there could be a planet a billion
miles away where they're making
fake games also in another planet a
billion miles away so
and then on each planet there are nearly
infinite
simulations so the odds that this is
base one becomes smaller and smaller and
smaller the more chances there are right
so let's say on earth alone there are
a hundred million computers running
simulations right
and then there's base reality so base
reality which is indistinguishable from
the simulations
is now one of a hundred million so the
chance that
we are in base reality becomes one in a
hundred million just on that one planet
alone
so if you have a hundred million planets
you can do the math the chance that
we're in base reality just gets smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller
right so eventually the idea that we're
based reality almost becomes impossible
because of the infinite possibilities so
that's the math behind simulation
if you run a simulation a million times
the chance that the first time you run
it
it becomes one in a million um
you know so that's that's the way they
look at it it gets confusing but the
other way
well maybe this isn't even possible so
in fact there is no stimulation because
it's not even possible to make oh it's
so possible
it gets really weird but i love this
kind of conversation i think it's better
drunk or stoned but i'm definitely great
and of you know
talking about the simulation theory yeah
yeah i agree
um okay so where can people find you
what are your final words
um um that's the best place to find me
or
you know yeah that's you can you can you
can message me on twitter i mean you
come to my twitter and then
if you have some great idea or whatever
like that but i'm always sort of
tweeting about bitcoin and then whatever
else comes to mind and uh
yeah thanks so much i appreciate it um
this was a lot of fun
thanks so much for coming on it's been
absolutely amazing
um i had all those questions so i'm so
glad i got to talk to them and
talk to you about them so thank you so
much um and guys don't forget to tune in
next week
thursday um 12 est back to normal time
ben
thank you so much thank you awesome bye